one thing I want to ask is uh every time
we hang out especially if Sydney is here
as well you guys always Bond over like
horror movies and horror media and I
like so I want to ask you what do you
find the appealing in like horror movies
because I have some I've been someone
who's like never been into horror movies
and I've never understood Cindy's
fascination with it so I thought I'd ask
you instead okay so there's a couple of
things like once you've seen enough of
any like genre or medium you start to
understand the subtleties to it and you
start to appreciate like this the little
differences between it yeah but like so
like there is that side of it but a
broader side of it like there's there's
two things with horror I think horror
out of any genre is about like
breaking rules and taking down
boundaries so something like Halloween
right it's like this whole society that
is set up to protect you it can't
against this one dude it is like this
nightmare scenario where like you're
[__] you know I'm like there's there's
something to that like I don't know like
just the kind of like
the break of normality but then another
part of it is like when a horror movie
is really well done and really like
scares the [__] out of me yeah
it doesn't matter what's going wrong in
my personal life or the work I'm
stressed out about or like you know this
issue I have with some person or
whatever because in that moment I'm like
this dude's [__] family's been
kidnapped and they're gonna die like it
it replaces whatever anxieties you might
be feeling in normal life you know what
I mean and so I like that there's like a
relief to her right what would you say
then is like the best because I'm kind
of the same way with gone
like yeah what do you think I like some
I guess like if if you were to try and
get someone into horror what would be
some like movies or shows or media yeah
what's the best horror movie for
non-horror Movie watches so I think if
you haven't watched a lot of horror
movies I think slasher movies are
generally a good way to go because
they're kind of like they're kind of
like the the death note
and that like you can show them to
someone normal and they'll get it the
rules are simple and like so something
like starting them off with something
like I think Halloween the original
Halloween still actually kind of rules
right Scream the original scream is
still a really good time yeah and from
there it's like it depends like you know
what the person reacts to the original
like Nightmare on Elm Street like
there's a lot of those kind of old like
Mega Blockbuster ones that are great
yeah because I wouldn't necessarily
start someone off with like The Shining
because like The Shining is just a film
that's trying to [__] you up the entire
way and like it can be kind of upsetting
in that it's like it's like someone
who's not used to spicy food nearly you
know
that's exactly what I am every time
Sydney piss on the horror movie I'm like
Cindy this is way too spicy I said that
and I was like well that's a stupid
[__] announcement I wish I could get
into horror I'm not not afraid of it at
all I just don't I don't know I I never
feel compelled by anything in horrible
horror games
um because that's like kind of a little
bit different right because it's a
you're a little more engaged in this
yeah you find a bit more engaging yeah
because I some sometimes it's [__]
terrified do you count fear and hunger
as a horror game uh
uh I think that's just an anxiety
I mean I I think the first time I ever
yeah
I'm scared I'm the most scared I've been
playing a game in a long time but I mean
we can talk about that for like 10 hours
I mean I can so yeah because I think you
got Connor into fear and hunger yeah
your video [__] me up man I'm I'm I'm
so addicted to that game now uh yeah no
I saw your video and there's a lot of
videos that I watch of yours where I
will watch the first two minutes and
I'll be like okay I don't want to watch
the rest I want to experience this thing
uh and sometimes I actually forget to go
and experience it so it really sucks for
the YouTube out there
because
you must think like man this guy hates
this video whereas the Garfield one I'm
like I'm never gonna get into Garfield
so I'm gonna watch this whole thing but
like if you're hung him on it was like
two minutes in I was like okay uh I had
a stream that day and I had I had
something else planning I was like oh no
[__] it I'm just gonna I'm gonna bite
the bullet I'm gonna play this game and
I remember when I was told in the
viewers I was like okay guys we're gonna
play this game
um John made a video about it uh and it
seemed [__] up and everyone was like
oh God oh God oh God and then some there
was only like four people because no one
else knew what it was I saw that I
watched that I watched part of that
stream and I saw you being like him wait
there's dicks in it yeah I was like wait
I didn't see that in John's video in two
minutes of that and so I was originally
gonna play It Uncensored until uh people
were like the people who had played it
were like please play this sensor please
uh and I realized okay well I'm gonna
make this and do a YouTube video so I
should probably play the centered
version uh and immediately I was
terrified just right away because it was
just like
I just immediately I was like oh my God
this is [__] horrifying what do I do
I'm getting [__] by everything and I
don't know where to go and the sounds of
oh The Sounds in that game are just the
worst and this is kind of there's this
track that plays initially and the first
time it plays I feel like it terrifies
everyone and everyone I've watched play
the games the exact same response it's
somewhere that that dooming noise the
booming like kind of uh it's like a bass
that kind of gets louder and louder yeah
yeah initially you feel like something's
about to happen and it never does but it
keeps looping and it's it's horrifying
and not to mention the fact there's
these dogs that chase you initially and
they're the also he needs to [__]
balance the audio on these dogs because
it's so loud these dogs and it's the
most violent crunchy dog sounds it is
horrifying right uh and then you just
get you'd lose to a coin flip and then
you're like
how did you reverse Vine fear and hunger
so the first time I ever saw it was like
um I think it was like some guy doing
like monster lore videos on Tick Tock I
couldn't believe this is how you got
into it and um he I can't even remember
which monster he did it on but I was
like
came seems kind of [__] up and then um
I then like a couple of weeks later this
is YouTube I really like called modular
and modular there's like a lot of old
and weird games he did a video on RPG
Maker games and um he had like a little
section on fear and hunger and he's
literally liking it I just want to say
[__] the people who made this game like
he liked it but like he was doing a bit
where he was like what the [__] is wrong
with this game you know and then I was
like oh this uh
yeah say less and then so then like I
played a little bit and then then like I
kind of played about I think 10 hours on
I was like yeah this seems pretty cool
and then like um there was another video
I think by called Oldman TV that went a
little deeper on it and that kind of
convinced me to like get into it
properly and then I was just obsessed
and then I just made it I just made the
video because I was like well here's a
fun way to spend a month playing these
games
what blew my mind most about that game
uh is that it came out in 2018. crazy
isn't it and it's so terrifying to think
that uh it took five years for this game
to really start getting some serious
traction for sure uh do you think about
how many amazing gems out there have
just been lost oh yeah that we will
never ever hear about I feel especially
in the RPG Mega world yeah there's
probably
there are games out there that would
have done like what undertale did that
we just don't even know about yeah just
no one's ever played five people have
played yeah uh and just because the
because I guess sometimes you just need
the right person to see it to start that
Chain Reaction right sure and it's tough
but uh [__] Tick Tock
Strikes Back listen I I watch too much
Tick Tock yeah but it's like the the
fascinating thing about that game is
that you play the game and like you said
you get 10 hours and you have an
experience with it and you think wow
okay I've played this game and then you
watch your video and you're like I did
not play this game I had a very
different experience and then you play
it again and you watch a lot of lore and
you think you understand everything and
then suddenly you find more information
out and it can every just everything
keeps changing your complete
understanding of the game uh and it's
really I was saying I was saying to you
the other day that um I think it's
really fortunate that the second game is
already out because I felt that it added
a lot of really cool layers of story to
the world that is already fascinating
and we didn't have to have that whole
thing of what is he making a second one
where's another one coming out I mean
fair play to that dude who was like
braved in his game enough that even
though like it never blew up huge he had
a second one ready so then when the
first one did blow up yeah yeah that's
crazy I loved I loved your your the one
thing that you said that sold me on it
was that it was only popular in Russia
that's that's how you know it's [__]
up I was like oh it must be messed up
because they only like [__] up [__] uh
and yeah I think uh undertale meets
berserk was a great way of explaining
that to some people yeah I mean it wears
its Inspirations very heavily on its
sleeve which some people criticize
um which I think it sometimes can be
valid but I mean I think it's a thing
though like you know when something is
really like reference heavy right like
some people love that and sometimes it's
like
I get that a little bit well you played
the second one there's a lot more
references in the second game in the
first game yeah and when you say
references well there is they're just
it's it's just children yeah JoJo is
just in the game what uh
yeah I'll show you a picture of this uh
uh okay
uh well just like like the model of
Johto is in the game like is he a
playable character or what
all right okay let me uh this guy this
is this is this is Marco from from uh oh
my [__] god that's jotor and he uses
his fists only
um this is this is him uh oh my God
there's also another character uh
it's a goat and he yeah and then there's
uh you can type in fear and hunger Levi
uh and uh
no but this one's gonna give him the
vibe yeah but like and you know the
second game is set in the terminal
Festival a festival uh that has a moon
that comes closer to the Earth I wish
[Music]
it's crazy because like it does have a
lot of stuff it doesn't feel crazy
though it doesn't feel like anything
else right like it actually does feel
pretty cohesive when you're playing it's
super weird yeah because yeah like that
and then there's also like the uh the
herbs you mix red and blue herbs to make
healing potions like in Resident Evil
and this there's so many things that
feel slightly familiar but it somehow
makes it feel so fitting and it doesn't
it doesn't feel that way at all and Matt
my God just some of the coolest [__]
law of any game I've ever played oh yeah
really super cool is there any other
like horror movies or things that have
like stood out to you that you've
watched recently recently
um
oh man I watched a film called I think
it's soft and quiet recently and it was
like
even by my standards it was like
probably shouldn't have watched that uh
it's it's if I guess if you like extreme
horror it's one of them I don't even
want to get into it but they but yeah
even I have my limits and that was I
felt bad because I was like Michelle do
you wanna know and like she's she's
learned to
um yeah it's really [__] up and it
deals with some pretty awful [__] yeah
but um it's uh it's an interesting well
I'd never seen that before put it that
way the light's a dislocation
what do you because you know a lot of
there are a lot of horror movies
actually I've seen these YouTube videos
that are like top 10 most extreme horror
movies like horror movies that maybe go
a bit too far how do you as a like what
do you think makes a horror movie that
like how do you like kind of dance that
line so I would say like I think the
idea of like extreme horror movies gets
like it's a good way to get clicks and
stuff but what I'd say is like I've been
watching horror movies a long long time
and to me like I don't really give a
[__] if a movie is Extreme I can't like
if it's doing interesting things yeah
because like you can you can make stuff
that's like not that gory and not like
that kind of like bloody or anything
yeah like um like The Shining doesn't
even really have any violence in it
there's no point where anyone hurts
another person in The Shining you know
there's a lot of [__] weird stuff and
like that's the kind of stuff I really
love yeah I mean I think the only one
I've enjoyed recently I don't even know
if this counts as a horror I think it
might be more a thriller but what's it
called again it's like the chef or the
table or
the menu I think the menu
let this man
do you guys want to write this movie
just recreating the table but it's just
really a chef gun there is a movie
called that's probably why I thought of
that no it's not it's not a horror movie
yeah I mean I just thought it was a
really interesting concept and it's kind
of like a satire on like the fine dining
culture and it was just very well acted
you know yeah it was fun I've noticed
that it's been on every single plane
I've ever been on uh the menu is on
every single viewable device I don't
know why it's much I think people are
just watching it from there yeah it's
really good I mean I liked it I I
wouldn't for me that didn't feel like
horror though in a weird way I suppose
yeah yeah yeah I mean it definitely I I
don't know if it was a horror or a
thriller it very because maybe because
it wasn't very gory you know that's
that's to me that's to me it it's still
like not a fan of girl it's still like
unnerved me which is what I like with
the types of horror movies I like when
it's like unnerving like same thing it's
gonna say where it's like if it's
interesting it's interesting but like I
wouldn't just play what happened to them
recent recent horror movie I watched I
guess all maybe it's more of a thriller
was um the new Aries to film The Bow is
afraid I haven't seen that yet it's
[__] weird that is like the only
thing I've heard about it is it's weird
and it's like three hours it's yeah it's
like two and a half hours it's one of
the weirdest films I've ever seen But
like it's almost
amazing it's it's one of those films
where it's like it completely depends on
the mood where it's like you can watch
it and be like this is just nonsense
horseshit or it could be this is
absolute Masterpiece yeah I've always
preferred horror when it's more of a
kind of human element to it and more of
a kind of relationships and how that
could be construed into horror like the
psychological aspect yeah yeah yeah
like yeah I'm trying to think of some
examples but I can't off the top of my
head but yeah I much prefer that as
opposed to [__] ghost that uh haunts
you and uh turns you into uh a zombie
there was a ghost with a gun
you like the ones whereas like and
humans were the real monsters all along
I just like damn it again yeah I mean I
just like it when it's like
unintentional or like it's like you know
it's just horrific because it's kind of
like wow it's yeah we are kind of [__]
up aren't we we do kind of occasional
[__] up stuff yeah like the more like
believable [__] you mean right like the
Invisible Man I thought was pretty good
it in terms of like the possessiveness
of an ex-boyfriend who is [__]
psychotic and yeah how that could
obviously you use the invisible way as a
kind of tool to kind of push it forward
but like you can kind of understand that
it's still pretty scary if he's not
invisible yeah he was terrifying when he
was invisible and the idea and the
thought of and I just I just loved how
it's it's this whole thing of it's
invisible but obviously the whole the
horror behind it is that he's just so
[__] creepy yeah but I mean that's
the thing of it are like you can like no
matter how [__] zany it can be like
someone being invisible you can ground
it in something real and like that it
resonates you know yeah I mean like I
think one of I I have like this soft
spot for it's not just horror but just
like low budget films where they have to
like make films with the constraint but
this one happens to be a horror I think
uh Sydney showed me the invitation I
think where it kind of without spoiling
it kind of details a you know a guy who
got an invitation from a long-lost
friend who yeah this one one uh who
basically uh is this the one this might
not be the one actually I don't know
maybe I got the maybe I got the [__]
name wrong again
a year ago sorry so it pretty is okay so
I'm not sure if this is the exact one
but uh it's it's it details like I got
two stars okay okay yeah this uh this
this looks like it's the one actually
yeah
um I it's it deals with a more
psychological aspect of you get an
invitation from someone that you hadn't
heard from for a long time and you can
tell that something is off and you can
tell that something is wrong and then
there will be this point where the
tension builds up and then like
something snaps and then [__] hits the
fan and I [__] love that so there's
another film called
um
I think it's called all my friends hate
me and it's it's that kind of same thing
but it's basically like the same setup
and it's like this guy shows up to a
mansion with [__] I hope we're not
talking about the same movie and I
haven't got the name wrong
uh yeah that's the one and this guy
shows up to a mansion and there's just
something off about the way his friends
are treating him yeah and it's basically
like the way the way one of my friends
described it was like it's like a social
anxiety horror movie
dude you should check out
so much more interesting then you would
love bows afraid because that is exactly
what that movie there's this bit where
this other guy shows it's like the most
unnerving [__] I've seen in the longest
time this other guy shows up at the at
the mansion and he's like well who's
this guy he was never friends with us
and he says some and the main character
says something about his sister and he
just sees like this new guy take out a
little notepad and write it down and
then put the notepad away and it's like
what the [__] it's great it's really
good do you often find find that horror
sometimes struggles to land an ending
because it's something I always found
that I didn't enjoy with horror films
that often halfway through I feel like
they often lose steam uh when they're
kind of the initial interesting concept
has to be explored more yeah and it kind
of is like I would find that a lot and I
feel like it clashes with this thing in
storytelling where we want explanations
and I think a lot of times horror is
weaker because of explanations yeah
because like the thing about horror is
like a lot of it's like what if this
[__] crazy thing came into your life
and you had to deal with it and if at
the end it's like and then you deal with
it it nearly stops being horror you know
yeah sure I think one of the best
endings to any horror media I've
consumed at least was probably Soma uh
it's a video game yeah oh my God that's
that you can talk about this in a
podcast once as well I think yeah that
ending like [__] me up it was kind of
like it was you know it kind of alluded
to something happening and then it kind
of like flipped it on his head and and
it kind of like that was that ending is
like stuck to me to this day that's yeah
but I know what you're talking about
awesome
wild [__] yeah basically if you haven't
played Soma I hate horror I hate horror
media but Soma is 100 something I would
recommend you guys play yeah